hi there Steve Kaufman today I'm going
to talk about something a little
different from my normal language
learning subject and I'm going to talk
about what I considered to be the
dishonesty of some so-called you know
advocates do-gooder advocates I became
aware today that Justin Trudeau who is
an aspiring political figure in Canada
Member of Parliament son of former Prime
Minister Pierre Trudeau hoping to become
the next leader of the Liberal Party and
I should point out that the Liberal
Party in Canada is kind of like the
Democrats in the u.s. sort of a left of
center party not quite as aligned with
the unions because we have another party
here called the New Democrats who are
more aligned with the unions but still
very much on the left of center when it
comes to their attitudes towards a
variety of policy issues and Pierre
Trudeau is a great they're not Pierre
but Justin Trudeau is is you know very
much setting himself up as you know
defender of the downtrodden or certainly
the middle class which everyone likes to
feel they belong to and fighting off
evil corporate interests and so forth
and Pierre Trudeau likes to go and talk
to schools talks to schools talks at
various he was at literacy for life for
example which is a pro literacy
organization that raises money for
literacy to combat the problems with
literacy Mental Health Association and
so forth and it turns out the Pierre
Trudeau who has been a member of
parliament for at least four years makes
a very good income giving these speeches
he may he charges $20,000 anywhere from
ten to twenty thousand dollars to go to
talk to a school to the literary source
literacy associate I find that just
appalling I find that so dishonest a
member of parliament is paid by the
taxpayer to be a political
representative to do things on behalf of
his
constituents and to be active
politically and raising awareness about
different issues and it's natural that a
member of parliament would go and give
talks at schools or other places like
that but to collect fees of ten to
twenty thousand dollars undoubtedly plus
expenses to me is completely dishonest
you know I happened to look up you know
he spoke at this literacy for life
association of Alberta and it says on
their website where they're promoting
you know donate support us because we're
fighting literacy get the word out about
literacy and learning forty-eight
percent of adults in Alberta have
difficulty with literacy that interferes
in their day-to-day life and almost
forty-eight percent half of them have
major difficulty that greatly impact on
their homework and community life says
who forty-eight percent of Albertans the
claims this article have literacy
difficulties and you know the fastest
way for them to improve their literacy
level it's not to give money to this
organization not to enlist the services
of some a literacy tutor because you
couldn't possibly find enough to tutor
forty-eight percent of the population of
the province they just need to get out
and read and that's something that they
could do any time they wanted to if they
just need to take responsibility of the
wrong reading they don't like to read
that's why they watch TV that's their
choice you know and there is nothing
that this literacy Association can do
about it but it's very good because when
they're promoting you know donate to our
cause forty-eight percent of adults have
trouble reading donate to our cause we
need to get the word out but then they
pay twenty thousand dollars to have
justin trudeau who in my mind in any
case is an airhead the only thing he has
going forward for him is that he's
Pierre Trudeau's son pay him twenty
thousand dollars now I I got curious i
look up like Al Gore Al Gore is this
great advocate for wind farms and solar
power and all this other stuff he
charges a hundred thousand dollars to go
and talk
and first class air travel to and from
New York or where he lives in tennessee
regardless of how he gets the venue he
collects the equivalent of first-class
air travel but where does he talk he
doesn't talk none of these people like
Justin Trudeau or or Al Gore they don't
talk to the thousand-dollar a plate you
know Wall Street bankers association
they talked to schools the the reference
I found with regard to Al Gore was from
a speech he gave at the University of I
don't know Southern California San Diego
so these are institutions public
institutions that are funded by the
taxpayer and then hand out a hundred
thousand dollars to have someone come
and say stuff that they're quite happy
saying anyway because that's they've set
themselves up as as these great
promoters of this cause I just find that
appalling appalling I can't count the
number of times that I have gone to give
speeches to immigrant groups here in
Vancouver I have mentored maybe 20 or 30
immigrants have come through our office
I spent time with them our employees
have spent time with them we never get
paid for doing this I don't get paid to
go and give speeches to the local
immigrant services organization i've
gone to have fireside chats with
immigrants i've tried to organize the
rotary and got them roped into giving
fireside chats to enter immigrants all
this kind of stuff to help with
immigrant literacy I wouldn't dream of
charging for that I just find that
absolutely appalling and I think that
people should be more concerned about
when they you know it when they consider
donating money to a charity where is
this charity spending the money and if
there is a speech even if it's a
fundraising event they should only
invite people who are prepared to donate
their time to that fundraising event I
think it's absolutely appalling that
that Al Gore charge is a hundred
thousand dollars for a speech to say
stuff we've heard him say many times
before and ditto for Justin Trudeau so
that's my thing today I just I'm
absolutely flabbergasted that that this
kind of thing
goes on I hope that it reflects poorly
on on Justin Trudeau anyway sorry to
wander off my usual language learning
subject but i'm just still just can't
get over the fact that he charges
$20,000 to go to a school to talk to
educators anyway thanks for listening
and if somebody wants to pay me twenty
thousand dollars to go and talk to us
cool i will tell them to take that
twenty thousand dollars and contribute
it towards education or do something
else with it instead of giving it to me
and i should continue Justin Trudeau has
an annual income from his speeches well
in excess of 200 thousand dollars not to
count his inheritance from his father he
doesn't need the money he doesn't need
and he has his income as a member of
parliament it's just appalling and I
don't know how rich Al Gore is and
there's many more like him I think we
need to wisen up to some of the scams
that are going on here I expect a great
avalanche of nasty comments thanks for
listening bye for now